day off on
yeah they officer myself
[Music]
you're supposed to be in clothes what
this is the female form
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no I got here first it's only fair I
took today off first no I told you weeks
ago I was taking today on the same day I
bought this tape well you never told me
that yes I did
no Garrick you didn't I would have
remembered are you sure I didn't tell
you when you were asleep actually when I
say that I'll add that I sent back you
talked to me in my sleep sometimes
okay your mom cause you said her flight
was delayed up to it okay you got a
parking ticket I'm just gonna put it in
a drawer next team was here you sleep a
lot well let's just agree to pretend
that the other one isn't here today I
mean like I do every day doesn't say
[Music]
take the remote take the road oh my god
Stan those white woman tears yeah
[Music]
Hey Dude looking for this our only spoon
20 piece utensil set or 20 pack of
sports what you're almost done
nope well then why'd you let me pour the
milk nicely done I got the remote I'll
just use the little right there was like
a it was like a big spoon anyway so
that's what I'm just gonna use I'm just
gonna use H there it is it's like a lot
of effort sit down
it's not even a so I'm gonna hook up in
my huh oh that work out for you Oh No
okay come on swim thank you strategy oh
my god here your real penis [ __ ] yard
sale down the street is getting rid of
this perfectly good drum set and I was
like well got nothing else to do today
might as well work on my rhythm of a
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we created this you tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right what about Garrick and the
rest what about Kate and company mud
slinging dirt mistake eyelash rain
chubby bunnies according to your mom but
the two is a roman numeral two weird
bottles tree scare Ginga fide deep ears
baby skulls star gather what happened to
Nelly stuck poop emoji popped pimple
uneven sleeves
how about loose tooth McGee dicks
ingrown hair baby feet wood paneling
uh-oh here come that man wear pencil
fingers ding-dong-ditch
period sex dressing room bloated cars a
space between your eyes bowel syndrome
empty swimming pool the part in that
dream where you can't run away but you
feel like you have to run but you're
only running in slow motion you're
carrying a sleeping better you don't own
flaccid penis out of toilet paper
correct penis mmm I like plugs
[Music]